-Hey, guys.
The new "Gran Turismo 7"
is out today.
Thank you, Sony,
for sending it over.
I love 6.
This is kind of the reason
to get a PS4, PS5.
The graphics on these
are just so awesome.
This is available
on PS4 as well as PS5.
We're playing it on a PS5
for the first time right now.
Here we go.
"Gran Turismo 7."
All right, so I'm gonna
go into the world map,
and there's so many spots
you can go.
You can change the brand,
you can change --
You can go to Legend Cars.
Let's just go to the garage
and pick a car here.
There's over 400 cars
you can choose from.
Look at that --
Volkswagen Beetle.
That's kind of fun.
That's kind of comedy.
But we're doing this one here --
McLaren VGT.
Wow.
Look at this thing.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Look at that.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
So, you get out of the garage,
you go over to world circuits.
Daytona.
That's classic.
Let's start.
Let's do this.
All right.
Oh, my --
It is fast.
Whoa! The trigger
has a little pushback.
I love this!
Sony, you did it!
Pulling the trigger
is actually hard.
It feels like
you're pulling -- you're --
This is like a gas.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
How fast am I going here?
340, 350...
360 miles an hour.
Now I gotta make the turn.
What are you doing?
Everyone is like,
"What are you doing, Fallon?!
Don't mess up the thing
for all of us, please!"
All right.
Here we go.
We're in kind of
a straightaway here.
Just gonna floor it -- 320.
I'm on the grass.
I'm back on track.
Oh, I spun out!
Yeah, sorry. Bad, bad.
All right, this is bad.
All right.
Don't freak out.
Dude, the triggers
are freaking out right now
'cause they know it.
Oh, this is amazing
what Sony's done.
Look at the colors coming off
the reflection off the car.
It's got such a good vibe to it.
And I could see --
Spun out again.
Going off the track.
It's all right.
We'll master it one day.
This is fun.
This is so fun.
All right.
So...
Finished.
There we go.
Fifth place -- not bad.
You know, up from 8th to 5th.
I'll take it, you know?
Five is a good number.
You know, that's how many
fingers I have on this hand.
So that's cool.
And the other five
are on this hand,
I use them both to play
"Gran Turismo 7."
Five and five --
five and five equals seven.
Thank you, Sony.
I'm gonna go play again.
This game's awesome.
Go pick it up.